le contraste est saisissant entre ce
semblant de vie normale que les guinéens
tente très fort de préserver et le
combat qu'il livre contre la pire
épidémie d'ebola de l'histoire les
employés et bénévoles de médecins sans
frontières en majorité des guinéens sont
offrant de cette guerre là vous entrez
un petit peu au coeur de la zone
désolation la zone d'isolation derrière
ces tentes c'est là où l'on soigne les
malades contagieux et surveille ceux en
attente d'un diagnostic depuis deux
semaines conakry connaît une nouvelle
flambée de contamination soit c'est un
problème puisqu'on n'arrive plus à
trouver suffisamment de suffisamment le
staff pour pouvoir travailler pour
pouvoir travailler fille pour un travail
à sion et volant la peur d'être infectés
rebute les humanitaires étrangers
les guinéens eux craignent davantage
d'être rejeté certains travaillent ici
sans que leurs familles sachent
mais ce n'est pas le cas de nice à tous
qui se prépare à aller changer les draps
du malade
oui c'est important pour moi
je veux servir mon pays qui l a ici un
jour donc je suis fin donc je ne peux
pas me distinguer des hommes pour dire
que ce que l'homme peut faire
moi je ne peux pas faire tout ce que
l'on peut faire moi il se touche pour le
faire on a travaillé pour sauver notre
nation
joseph travail qu'un menuisier sur le
site de msf
un labeur très pénible dans la chaleur
intolérable de cette combinaison
protectrice n'a pas coulé
pour mener des cordes médicaux on n'a
pas le choix et à l'épidémie de nous
celle aux parents on na li est
nécessaire de les aider ce médecin
guinée est basée à dakar est venu
prendre ses vacances ici on nous il
n'est pas reparti j'ai décidé que je
suis rentré en congé devenu portée
couplés aux médecins ici
tu as beau
c'est parce que là vous voyez pas mal de
médecins ont abandonné les hôpitaux les
médecins et les malades ne sont plus
maintenant vu à quoi il ya la peur de
l'épidémie donc ce qui fait que
franchement j'ai décidé de renier envoyé
ici ceux qui viennent au centre de
traitement de l'ebola pour l'argent ne
reste pas longtemps
le travail est trop dur physiquement et
mentalement on ne peut y résister sans
un engagement puissant des dès son
prochain une volonté qu'il communique
aux malades au point d'être devenu un
facteur de guérison peut avoir le
courage pour répondre parce que les
patients qui sont vraiment souffert il
ya doute recherche a écoulé la peur la
de la tête
et puis voilà ça passe vous allez va
avoir le courage
la force d'un tel dévouement touche même
des humanitaires d'expérience comme
stéphanoise s'est paradoxalement
certainement une de mes plus belles
missions parce que il ya une commande il
ya une très forte implication plus monde
et
un énorme sentiment ce constat n'est pas
un sentiment d'utilité c'est même au
delà de ça c'est que ce n'est même pas
qu'il faut faire ce travail c'est que
c'est indispensable de faire ça sinon à
si personne ne fait rien
il va y avoir une catastrophe d'une
ampleur inimaginable légende msf disent
qu'ils ne sont pas alarmistes mais
réaliste plusieurs nouveaux foyers de
contamination les inquiète et les
enfants relativement épargnée jusqu'ici
commencent à être infectées en plus
grand nombre
ici ce filon gloire radio-canada à
conakry